such an interesting mix this film has
that sort of timeless Hollywood classic
filter it also deals with such
contemporary issues is that sort of what
you got from your initial read of the
script yeah I think yeah I was excited
when I first read the script because I
had just spent the holidays with my
in-laws and we couldn't find a film that
we all wanted to see together and when I
read the script I just thought I've got
it this was in the movie theater right
now we wouldn't have had any problems
and I think that sort of speaks to your
question about there's some classic
storytelling well is set in the modern
world so no one felt alienated by it you
know so refreshing as well see a
platonic relationship between a man and
a woman on screen even with you guys
both Oscar winners pretty good actors
but you can't buy that chemistry can you
I don't know if you can buy it we both
got paid food it's not something we
worked at or thought about or ever
talked about so much if it was in the
writing and and we just got along
that's simple as that yeah I mean I
always wanted and to do it and so that
was never a thing for me but uh
you know I've you hear stories about
people who can be famous other stories
in old Hollywood these people hated each
other and yet the relationship and they
they had a couple of movies going and
it's not necessarily a sequence film but
a difference different movies different
stories supposedly that's kind of
interesting
so we tried that approach and it work
you can't watch this film without
thinking a little bit The Devil Wears
Prada but does it show how much
Hollywood has moved on the fact that in
that movie Meryl Streep this icy boss
and here your normal female boss with
normal issues you're not I see you're
not aggressive and you've got a man as
your intern I don't know I don't
I'm qualified to make any grand
statements about the current state of
the way things are but I think with
Jules Ostin it means that we're seeing a
different type of female boss and I
think we're used to seeing one kind and
maybe it means that people's views are
expanding so that's good you are
qualified in some respect the fact that
we read so much about female roles
drying up when you get older and
Hollywood is not equal like that are we
approaching some sort of parity do you
think define approaching the fact is
this movie is getting it's absolutely a
step forward and and and and I think
steps there are an icy steps being taken
every day you know I've started
producing and whenever I were trying to
find a director for it someone always
acts and asks and not always me where
the women on this list who were gonna do
we who are we gonna do this with
sometimes you go a little deeper you
look at someone who maybe they don't
have a future film yet they only have a
short film so I think people are aware I
think people not just women but men I
think the whole industry has been
embarrassed by the state of things when
you look at the numbers and I think
everybody or at least enough people are
trying to make it better that the needle
is moving it's going to take time of
course but I think there's a lot of
positive indicators because you've said
you're producing because perhaps you
means you can get to pick meteor roles
oh definitely definitely I think my
slate would be a lot more empty if if I
wasn't producing I'm Bobby is your
career sort of goes on you're getting
more eclectic in your taste is that it's
that sort of the beauty of being a bit
older and having the the CV that you've
got that you can say you know what
I fancy this fancy that yeah I mean I
I'll think anything that comes my way I
don't believe that something in yes
yeah of course I'm all the different
things that I'm offered that I that I
I'm within that zone of being believed
or believable as that character so yeah
and you spoke more than I've ever seen
you smile and screaming for a long time
there it is okay on that note than there
are smile or down